bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
filecho l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
Airbus Group a annoncé la semaine
dernière en détail le nombre de
suppression de postes pour chacun de ces
sites mais selon les syndicats il ne
s'agit pas là de donner des
deffinitive à l'heure où où les lycéens
pardon font leur choix d'orientation
quelle place tient l'artisanat nous
verrons si ce secteur attire les jeunes
et puis nous vivions la semaine dernière
l'inauguration en grande pompe du
Vélodrome national dans notre dossier de
la semaine nous nous intéresserons au
modèle économique de cette
structure et avec nos invités nous
parlerons de la Semaine de l'emploi
Saint-Quentin en Yveline des événements
auront lieu tous les jours du 7 au 14
février nous recevons donc Laurent Duma
bonsoir vous êtes directeur de l'emploi
et de la politique de la ville à la
communauté d'agglomération et face à
vous myiam bouslima bonsoir responsable
toute nouvelle responsable d'une agence
d'intérim à 50 ansol on se retrouve dans
un instant après les informations
économique 1500 1400 suppression de
postes chez Airbus group anciennement
EADS d'ici 3 3 ans nous vous
l'annoncions la semaine dernière on
parlait alors de 411 emplois touchés sur
le site d'élancour en cause la
restructuration du groupe qui comprendra
trois divisions parmi elles ADS Airbus
défense et et espace qui regroupera
Cassidian et Astrium 309 emplois seraiit
également touchés au Mureau mais pour le
syndicat CFE CGC ces chiffres sont à
prendre avec des pincettes puisque le
nombre total de salariés sur chaque site
avancé lors de cette annonce ne
correspondrait pas pas à la réalité
explication avec Philippe venglass
délégué syndical de cassidian il y a un
chiffre de 411 qui a été fait enfin
annoncé c'est un chiffre que donne la
direction mais ce chiffre pour moi il il
veut rien dire en tous les cas je sais
pas si ça concerne qu'assidien SAS je ne
sais pas si ça concerne que hencour en
faisant des plus et des moins il y a
notre filiale qui est sur hencour qui
fait plus 156 personnes dans 2 ans donc
si on dit que les 411 ça tient compte
qu' y en a 156 qui sont placés là on
monte à 560 suppression de poste nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est les
suppressions de poste c'est pas le bilan
final donc on a beaucoup de mal à suivre
ce que ça veut dire 411 aujourd'hui le
41 je sais pas à qui il s'applique à
quel contour est-ce que c'est aussi
notre filiale absciss qui est ass Suren
ou pas j'en sais rien et cassidian
comprend à 90 % des cadres donc dans
tous les cas ce sont des postes
hautement diplômés qui seront touchés
cela veutil veut-il-t-il dire pardon que
le secteur de l'aéronautique se porte
mal c'est ce que nous avons voulu savoir
nous avons rencontré un conseiller d'air
emploi une association d'orientation
spécialisé dans l'aéronautique selon lui
il y a des besoins dans ce secteur pour
tout niveau de formation et les filles
sont bienvenues on l'écoute on recrute
du CAP au bac+ 5 spécialisé dans
l'aéronautique ou
industriel donc c'est un secteur
évidemment qui recrute des ingénieurs et
des techniciens sur toutes ces fonctions
mais c'est un secteur qui notamment sur
les métiers de la production recrute
aussi des CAP et des bac pro c'est un
secteur qui recrute actuellement et qui
recrutera dans les années à venir en
raison d'une augmentation continue du
trafic passager en raison aussi du
besoin des compagnie aériennes besoin
permanents d'avoir des avions toujours
de plus en plus économiques de plus en
plus écologiques et on va dire que ce
secteur recrute en fait sur toutes ces
grandes familles de
métiers le le mouvement de protestation
des salariés de SKF France le leader
mondial dans le domaine du roulement
mécanique continue sur le site de
Montini une trentaine de personnes
étaient en grève lundi ils ont bloqué
symboliquement les accès pour les
voitures en cause le PSE le plan de
sauvegarde de l'entreprise qui prévoit
une restructuration 51 salariés de
Montini doivent être transférés sur un
deuxième site à saincir sur Loire près
de tour la direction a prévu un plan
d'accompagnement pour les salariés
concernés mais les syndicats cf
CGC et CGT s'inquièteent pour les
personnes qui ne pourraient ou ne
voudraient pas déménager ils ont assigné
SKF en justice la décision est attendue
le 13 février la direction tente de ce
côté de faire voter un accord
majoritaire auprès des syndicats CFDT et
foo c'est-à-dire les syndicats
majoritaires sur sacir sur Loire le
comité central d'entreprise doit donner
son avis lundi prochain depuis le 20
aucune condition significative nous a
permis d'arrêter le la bagarre puisque
notre direction fait la sour
d'oreille ne répond pas aux
interrogations posé par le personnel à
savoir quel est ce motif de transfert
quel est le motif économique pourquoi
des avant significative existe sur le
Saint- surloire et pas pour le personnel
de
Montini tout ça nous avons pas de
réponse la situation financière DESCF
est complètement
saine une moyenne de 50 à 70 millions
sont distribués régulièrement tous les
ans aux actionnaires le PSE devrait être
à la hauteur des résultats d' SKF ce
n'est pas le cas du 4 au 7 février l'
dit l'Association pour le droit à
l'initiative économique organise la
Semaine du micro crédit un moyen de
faire connaître ce système de
financement pour de petites entreprises
parmi les événements organisés
l'association proposé mercredi des
rencontres individuelles avec des
porteurs de projet des images d'étien
Dang
Mourat cherche à lancer son entreprise
une société de coursiers à vélo autour
de Versailles mais pour cela il a besoin
de financement ce mercredi il est venu
se renseigner auprès de lad
l'Association pour le droit à
l'initiative économique une journée
d'information était organisée au
Promopole de trappe dans le cadre de la
Semaine du microcrédit le but favoriser
les projets de personnes exclues du
crédit bancaire pour ça je me suis
tourné vers eux par parce que les
banques je suis pas trop je suis FRIL un
peu par rapport à eux parce que je sais
que ça va être négatif vu que je suis
demandeur d'emploi voilà c'est pour ça
jeis appel directement parce que moi
c'est un minimum que je demande c'est à
peu près une somme de 5000 € à peu près
après on verra si ça va être accepté
quoi surtout le montage du du du dossier
surtout qui va être
important pour eux à leurs yeux dans la
plupart des cas les bénéficiaires du
microcrédit sont des demandeurs d'emploi
ou des allocataires du RSA laad leur
permet de financer leur projet pour un
montant maximum de 10000 € donc nous on
est un
financeur donc on évalue s'ils sont au
bout du projet de création ou pas s'ils
le sont pas on les réoriente vers nos
partenaires de montage de projets et
s'ils le sont bah du coup on étudie leur
dossier on leur donne une
première un premier avis sur la
possibilité de financement ou pas et
donc il repartent
d'ici j'espère avec des conseils et un
peu plus de visibilité sur leur sur leur
projet les conseillers finanç moyenne
un/art des projets soumis 84 % des
micro-entrepreneurs suivis par
l'association se sont réinsérés
professionnellement quel métier je
voudrais exercer plus tard c'est la
question auquelle tente de répondre de
nombreux jeunes en ce début d'année pour
les aider dans leur choix d'orientation
des forums des métiers sont organisés un
peu partout dans le département le
weekend dernier un été organisé à
fontené le Fleury les métiers de de
l'artisanat étaient sur représentés
alors est-ce que ce secteur a le vent en
poupe réponse avec ce reportage réalisé
avec Patrick Jacques de
dixmud pas facile quand on est collégien
ou lycéen de savoir vers quel métier
s'orienté le weekend dernier responsable
d'école et professionnels étai présents
au forum intercommunal de fontener
lefleur le but présenter l'offre
existante sur le territoire parmi eux la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat un
ferronier le CFA de Versailles ou encore
la Fédération française du bâtiment car
depuis quelques années le secteur de
l'artisanat a ti les jeunes et les
formations professionnalisantes comme
l'apprentissage ne sont plus reléguées
au seul décrocheurs scolairirees on a eu
par exemple sur le CFA de la Chambre des
Métiers à Versailles l'année dernière
autour de 150 à 180 demandes de jeunes
qui venaient nous rencontrer alors
qu'ils étaient déjà diplômés de
l'enseignement supérieur pour une
formation courte en un an et pour cause
80 % des jeunes de ce centre de
formation trouvent un emploi à l'issue
de leur apprentissage les métiers qui
attirent le le plus depuis quelques
années les métiers de bouche Antoine
pense au métiers de pâtissier c'est plus
pour l'instant un loisir mais pourquoi
pas comme on est en en 4e l'année
prochaine il a un stage à faire d'une
semaine donc pourquoi pas avoir un stage
de
pâtisserie les loisirs peuvent déboucher
à une envie de faire quelque chose plus
tard tous les métiers de l'artisanat ne
sont pas logés à la même enseigne les
salons de coiffure par exemple peine à
recruter plus atypique un ferronier
était également présent sur le site un
moyen selon lui de faire connaître la
réalité du métier d'artisan au-delà des
clichés ils sont intéressés par
l'artisanat ils savent pas vraiment par
quoi commencer ils ont surtout l'image
de l'artisan pas de l'artisan mais du du
gars sur le chantier voilà il
s'imaginent pas en tant que patron il
s'imaginent pas en tant qu'indépendant
et parfois ils savent même pas ce que
c'est quoi ils ont juste vu plombier ça
gagne Intel ça gagne mais ils ont pas
une vue globale de de ce que c'est que
l'artisanat de son côté le gouvernement
a lancé en janvier un pacte pour
l'artisanat de nouvelles mesures pour
attirer les jeunes vers ce secteur et
faciliter la reprise
d'entreprise demain vendredi 7 débute la
semaine de l'emploi à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline il s'agit là de la 18e édition
chaque jour des rendez-vous forum de
l'emploi découverte des métiers nous
allons voir tout ça en détail sur ce
plateau nous recevons Laurent Duma
bonsoir vous êtes directeur de l'emploi
et de la politique de la ville à la
communauté d'agglomération et face à
vous Miriam Bousnina cette fois je le
prononce bien responsable d'une agence
d'intérêtim à Saint-Quentin également
alors Laurent Duma en un mot finalement
cette semaine c'est l'occasion de de
faciliter l'insertion et la réinsertion
sur le marché du travail voilà alors les
objectifs de cette semaine sont
multiples puisqu'il s'agit de permettre
à des publics qui soient demandeurs
d'emploi en recherche de formation en
recherche d'orientation professionnelle
pour les plus jeunes mais également pour
un certain nombre d'adultes qui qui
souhaitent changer de métier de trouver
des réponsse en tout cas de les
accompagner d'avoir accès à des
ressources auxquelles ils n'auraient pas
nécessairement accès facilement tout au
long de de leur recherche donc il s'agit
vraiment de multiplier les temps de
rencontres avec les acteurs de l'emploi
avec les entreprises de cquanttin en
liveline qui recrutent alors un point
sur le chômage dans les Yvelines il a
augmenté de 8 % sur l'année B 2013 on
arrive un taux qui reste correct on va
dire entre guillemets 7 et5 % c'est
moins que la moyenne nationale de 10,5i
euh qu'en est-il sur 50 an nieline alors
50 an neline continue d'être
relativement privilégié si on peut dire
puisque le taux de chômage est dans la
moyenne départementale à peu près à 8
et5i % cela dit la situation reste
malgré tout préoccupante puisque nous
avons 7000 demandeurs d'emploi à 50 en
yeline 7000 demandeurs d'emploi en
catégorie A et nous sommes notamment
inquiets de la forte d'augmentation de
l'augmentation des demandeurs d'emploi
de plus de 50 ans qui est un véritable
problème aujourd'hui de société depuis 5
ans depuis 60 mois le nombre de seniors
demandeurs d'emploi n'a jamais cessé
d'augmenter alors pour ces demandeurs
d'emploi donc des forums seront
organisés on pense notamment à un grand
forum de recrutement le 13 on en parle
dans un instant vous avez voulu
également mettre l'accent sur deux
secteurs le secteur du bâtiment et des
travaux publics et l'intérime pourquoi
voilà alors parce que ce sont des des
secteurs alors notamment celui du
bâtiment qui peinene aujourd'hui à
recruter même si effectivement le volume
de construction est moins élevé en
2013-24 que les années précédentes cela
dit aujourd'hui on voit bien que ce sont
des métiers qui sont assez peu
attractifs et donc il faut redoubler
d'efforts pour revaloriser la filière
revaloriser les métiers du BTP et
rappeler également que ce sont des des
un secteur de l'activité où il y a de
véritables perspectives professionnelles
et des carrières qui se font souvent
assez rapidement alors alors
myiamousnina du côté de l'intérim qu'en
est-il est-ce que vous avez du mal à
recruter vous également pour l'instant
on a le problème qu'on a dans l'intérim
c'est les profils qualifiés donc on peut
trouver des manœuvres mais les profils
qualifiés donc par exemple surtout dans
le BTP c'est pour ça c'est très très dur
de retrouver des donc des profils pour
les entreprises en BTP c'est qu'ils
cherchent des personnes qualifiées et
les personnes qui se présentent
généralement à l'intérim c'est des
personnes qui n'ont pas vraiment
beaucoup de qualification voire pas
d'expérience donc malgré tout mais quand
même on arrive quand même à placer des
personnes et on arrive quand même à donc
à à les positionner même de par exemple
pour un a bardeur on les met pour un
bardeur on le met tout d'abord un N
bardeur pour arriver à la fin pour en
tant que bardeur avec l'expérience mais
c'est vrai que je pense que le le le
souci bon je je je vois tous les jours
des personnes qui se présentent à
l'agence qui demandent à trouver un un
emploi rapidement mais sauf qu'il y a
pas de qualification derrière euh c'est
la formation finalement exct exact un
titre qui m'a étonné un directeur
d'agence de de traap m'a indiqué que son
chiffre d'affaires av augmenté de 25 %
l'année dernière en 2013 finalement euh
malgré la crise l'intérim fonctionne
tout à fait tout à fait tout à fait
malgré la crise l'intérim s'en sort bien
et c'est pour cette raison aussi moi que
je je me positionne aujourd'hui en tant
que directrice d'agence à sa-qutin en
yvline donc si vous voulez puisque les
les les entreprises ne recrutent plus en
CDI en CDD donc quand ils ont un surquoi
d'activité ils font appel directement à
l'intérim son un peu frileux ils sont
bloqués les recrutements ça finalement
la crise le manque de visibilité pour
les entreprises c'est c'est du bonus fin
du bonus pour l'intérim mais après voilà
après c'est vrai que ça fait ça
fragilise un peu l'emploi mais voilà on
nous appelle pour desémissions d'une
journée de de 4h de 5h c'est vrai que
c'est peu mais quand même on répond aux
attentes des entreprises et aussi on a
des candidats qui souhaitent qui aussi
on a aussi beaucoup de d'intérimaires
qui ne souhaitent travailler qu'on
intérime et n'accepte pas des longues
missions de 3 ou 4 mois voilà c'est un
choix aussi après alors lors de de ce
forum donc de l'intérime qui sera
organisé le 10 février sera de 13h à 17h
au prisme d'l encour il y aura également
en fait des informations qui seront
délivrées sur le statut d'intérimaire
c'est important
de d'avoir oui bien sûr é même un point
de vue légal ils sont en train d'étudier
aussi un statut un nouveau statut
d'intérimaire en CDI donc c'est-à-dire
qu'il peut-être embauché par la l'agence
d'intterm mais c'est encore en cours
c'est pas encore donc valide je pense
que ça sera un profil intéressant quand
on a des profils rares en agence
d'intérim on peut les recruter en CDI
pour pouvoir après les présenter en
entreprise c'est pas du tout d'actualité
pour le moment mais c'est vrai que le
statut de les les les intérimaires ne
connaissent pas vraiment tous leurs
droits en tant qu'intérimaire mais c'est
vrai qu' moi de toute façon je donne
tout mon temps pour expliquer que même
pour expliquer leur fiches de paye les
indemnités de fin de mission les les
congés et tout ça donc c'est vrai que
c'est très très important pour eux aussi
de connaître leur droits par rapport à
ça à prendre en compte donc euh du coup
il y aura aussi un grand forum disons de
du recrutement ça sera jeudi prochain
celui-là tout la journée à l'hôtel
d'agglomération à traap là il y aura
vraiment beaucoup d'entreprises tout
secteur confondu voilà donc on a 60
entreprises he qui ont répondu présent
donc on a des entreprises privées comme
publ des grands groupes des PME
également et des plus petites
entreprises qui recrutent également
puisqueaujourd'hui on voit bien que ce
sont c'est le secteur des PME des TP qui
recrutent davantage que les grand
groupes voilà exactement qui eux ont
plutôt tendance à geler leur leur
recrutement alors il y achelle des
recrutements parce que il y a un manque
de de visibilité sur la conjoncture
économique pour les les mois qui
viennent très bien en tout cas on note
ces rendez-vous merci beaucoup à tous
les deux d'avoir été présent sur notre
plateau on passe à la pardon au dossier
de la
semaine la semaine dernière se tenait
l'inauguration du Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin en iveline un projet
sportif qui repose sur un partenariat
public privé les détails de ce modèle
économique avec notre dossier de la
semaine réalisé avec Jonathan villman et
Xavier
Jalin le vélodrome national une
structure de 3000 m² une piste de 250 m
un parcours BMX couvert une résidence
pour les sportifs on y trouve dorénavant
le Centre national du cyclisme et le
siège de la Fédération Française un
projet sport de taille prévu à la base
pour favoriser la candidature de Paris
au JO 2012 malgré la victoire de Londres
les pouvoirs publics ont souhaité
maintenir ce projet pour accroître la
renommée du territoire mais au-delà de
l'aspect sportif sur quel modèle
économique repose le vélodrome qui le
finance à la base quatre partenaires
publics l'État la Région le Département
et
l'agglomération il faut bien
dissocier
l'investissement le fonctionnement et
l'impact économique du Velodrome sur le
territoire sur
l'investissement c'est un objet on parle
bien du véodrome mais aussi de la piste
de BMX qui est la première piste couvert
en Europe de BMX ça a coûté 74 millions
d'euros ces 74 millions d'euros sont
financés par des subventions à part
presque égal entre l'État la Région le
Département et la communé d'aglomération
environ un peu plus de 50 millions de
subvention et le reste est financé dans
le cadre d'un partenariat public privé
avec nos partenaires privés que sont
mdiam et Bua il faut rajouter que dans
l'investissement dans les ressources
d'investissement on a pu vendre
l'agglomération a pu vendre pour plus de
12 millions d'euros de charges foncière
pour réalisation des logements étudiants
logement chercheurs hôtel bureaux ce qui
effectivement diminue le coût de
l'investissement et qui résouve à peu
près à 8 millions
l'investissement en 2009 les quatre
partenaires publics s'étaient accordés
sur une contribution de 13,36 millions
d'euros chacun mais quelques années plus
tard la réalité est différente le
Conseil général des Yvelines a opté pour
un investissement de 7,5 millions le
reste soit 5,8 millions serait prise en
charge par l'agglomération ce schéma
financier n'est pas du goût de tous un
groupe de citoyens s'est opposé au
projet de Vélodrome neuf in Montin ont
déposé en 2011 un recours au tribunal
administratif contre le Plan Local
d'Urbanisme le PLU qui a autorisé la
construction du Vélodrome sur ce terrain
et contre le permis de construire leur
argumentaire est écologique mais aussi
économique et à la suite de du recours
que nous avons déposé contre le permis
de construire vopolis nous a assigné au
tribunal de grande instance c'est donc
un autre tribunal pour nous demander des
dommager intérêt au prétexte que nous
leur aurions causé un tort financier et
temporel puisquil est qu'il y a du
retard vélopolis est une filiale du
groupe bug elle est le titulaire du
contrat de partenariat public privé et
s'occupe de l'entretien et de
l'exploitation du Vélodrome jusque fin
2039 pour les assignés de Montini comme
ces citoyens s'appellent c'est ce
partenariat public privé qui pose
problème si les Jeux Olympiques avaient
été attribué à Paris le financement
aurait été un financement national or
ici se retrouve que le même projet euh
est financé principalement par euh les
habitants de 5ant an evveline je dis
principalement parce que il est financé
à quatre parts une subvention de l'État
une de la région une du Conseil
département et une de Saint-Quentin si
bien que nous en tant que habitant de
Saint-Quentin on paye les quatre impôts
euh de plus euh il a également été
financé par une vente de terrain public
qui eux effectivement étaient des
terrains de la de la casquie donc tout
ça bah ça nous coûte cher et en plus
ensuite il faut voir le fonctionnement
et la communauté d'aglo doit payer
pendant 30 ans 4100000 € tous les ans
pour faire fonctionner ce projet 4100000
€ un montant conséquent mais qui selon
la communauté d'agglomération ne
correspond pas à la somme versée dans
les faits ce
loyer il est compensé par des recettes
des recettes liées à l'investissement je
dis 12 millions les plus de 12 millions
de charges foncières qu'on a vendu nous
apportent des recettes et puis aussi par
des recettes de fonctionnement alors
dans le fonctionnement qui est peu plus
de 2 millions d'euros par par an nous
avons déjà 1 million qui est une recette
de location vente j'irais à la
Fédération Française de de cyclistes
reste à à combler par un ensemble de
fonctionnement des recettes que ça soit
sur des manifestations sportives autes
que le vélo sur des manifestations
culturelles concert et autes ou
desévénements économiques qui peuvent
avoir lieu dans le vélodrome sur la
piste de BMX ou sur un espace qui est
entre le BMX et vrome donc tout ça ce
sont les recettes de fonctionnement
reste en plus dans le loyer une charge
d'entretien d'entretien du propriétaire
ce qui fait que dans 27 ans nous serons
propriétaires d'un équipement
neuf la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
paye un loyer annuel à hauteur d'un
million d'euros à l'agglomération mais
il s'agit là d'une location
si à la fin du contrat le vélodrome
appartiendra à la communauté
d'agglomération la Fédération sera
également propriétaire de ces bureau
nous avons contacté à de multiples
reprises le principal acteur de ce
partenariat public privé vélopolis la
société d'exploitation du Vélodrome n'a
pas donné suite à nos demandes
d'interview mais avait répondu en
décembre dernier aux inquiétudes liées à
ce modèle économique il y a pas que des
bons exemples sur la partie PPP en tout
cas celui de villodrome est plutôt une
réussite le recours porait pas en
l'occurrence sur le PPP mais plutôt sur
le PLU euh pour ce qui concerne le PPP
du Vélodrome on est un chantier qui
finit son dans l'é temp dans le budget
euh il y a une intervention d'un
exploitant privé avec un certain nombre
de garanties et puis surtout euh la
qualité de d'avoir un entretien une
maintenance et une qualité
d'exploitation euh posé sur le vélodrome
il y a pas de risque financier on est
plutôt dans un modèle où au niveau du
Vélodrome c'est l'exploitant privé qui
va reverser une part de ses revenus à la
communauté d'aglot donc on est plutôt
dans un dans un cas opposé et puis quand
bien même il y aura un vrai coup dur au
niveau de l'exploitation il faut savoir
qu'il y a une fédération résidente qui
verse elle-même des cotisations de loyer
pour ses bureaux son hébergement et
cetera et puis il y a un actionnaire qui
couvre encore la société
d'exploitation pour les partenaires du
PPP l'exploitation du site du Vélodrome
devrait permettre d'égaliser les coûts
au programme compétition cyclistes mais
aussi événements sportifs et culturel
une salle de spectacle accueillant 5000
personnes où l'on pourrait même
organiser des séminaires d'entreprise 25
événements sont déjà programmés sur
l'année les bénéfices seront partagés
entre vélopolice et l'agglomération là
encore les opposants au projet restent
sceptiques Lucien bugnol président de la
commission piste au comité régional
estimé en 2012 dans Le Parisien à titre
personnel je pense que Saint-Quentin est
trop décentralisé trop éloigné pour
beaucoup de clubs je reste sceptique au
Vélodrome maintenant de faire ses
preuves sur sa
rentabilité et on finit cette émission
avec l'agenda on vous rappelle la 18e
semaine de l'emploi Saint-Quentin en
iveline ça se passe du 7 au 14 février
pour les différents forums n'oubliez pas
votre CV les événements ont lieu dans
différents lieux plus d'information sur
le site de
l'agglomération et puis la communauté
d'agglomération toujours mais son
matériel usager en vente du mobilier des
outils du matériel reprographique et
scénique professionnel des enchères sont
donc organisées du 4 au 18 février ça se
passe en ligne sur le site d'agoraastore
les retraits d'objets se feront eux
début mars attraper aller en cours c'est
la fin de ce fil écho merci de nous
avoir suivi je vous donne rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine et d'ici là très bonne
soirée
for